[Music]
the ninth episode of star trek picard's
second season boldly goes where no trek
show has been before bringing us a
rarely seen version of the enterprise
and a shockingly dark past for a
character we thought we knew
during flashbacks to the childhood of
jean-luc picard we see the future
captain of the enterprise sitting at the
table in his family home on the table
near him is a toy sure to make trekkies
eyes wide a model of the nx01 refit the
nx01 is easily identifiable as the
titular starship featured in the four
season series star trek enterprise which
premiered in 2001 and starred scott
bakula as captain jonathan archer but
the refit aspect is what makes this
model especially unique because this
version of the nx01 enterprise was never
seen on screen it has only been the
subject of conjecture developed by
designers and model makers for a future
the series never saw the design was
originally planned to be introduced in a
fifth season of enterprise that never
happened thanks to an abrupt
cancellation in 2005 and has only ever
been seen off-screen artwork of the nx01
refit was seen in the 2014 release of
the star trek ships of the line calendar
series while polar lights produced a
model kit to the variant starship as
well in fact the version we see in this
episode appears to be a model produced
by eagle moss as part of their hero
collection series of star trek starships
in episode 9 titled hide and seek we
finally learn the truth behind picard
and his mother's games of hide and seek
a reference to a moment in the ninth
star trek film star trek insurrection in
that movie commander data is
malfunctioning and on the run leaving it
up to picard and wharf to track him down
while on the shuttlecraft captain picard
notes that as a boy he and his mother
used to play games of hide and seek
which we've seen firsthand this season
come out come out wherever you are
however we now learn there was far more
to those games than we ever imagined
here we discovered that a fateful game
of hide and seek led to a terrible
incident to picard's youth it started
innocently enough with a game in the
chateau but after a short time picard's
mother asks him to continue the game in
the tunnels beneath the estate picard
remarks that the tunnels are forbidden
but she manages to coax him down there
in the hopes of leaving the chateau
entirely his mother takes him through
the dark tunnel attempting to run from
her husband but jean-luc gets stuck in a
wooden floorboard his mother leaves
without him and young picard must be
rescued by his father later that evening
his mother suffers a severe mental
breakdown and takes her online adding
dark new context to a seemingly innocent
moment in star trek insurrection
ever since season 1 of star trek picard
fans have wondered what the deal is with
this new improved 7-9 what happened on
her adventures following star trek
voyager that caused her to turn to
vigilantism and the fenris rangers
rather than starfleet well thanks to
episode 9 of picard season 2 we finally
know why she turned out the way she did
the answer harkens back to several
episodes of star trek voyager while
running from the newly minted borg
soldiers in the tunnels beneath the
picard chateau 7 of 9 and rafi have
another heart to heart as they arm up
and prepare to take on a squad of
soldiers chasing them rafi comments at
seven who is taking command of the
situation sounds a lot like a starship
captain she says that seven should have
joined starfleet and it's then that we
learned why she never did finally giving
fans a deeper glimpse into what happened
to seven after returning to the alpha
quadrant in the star trek voyager finale
according to seven she did attempt to
join starfleet but was turned away
because of her time as a board drone
apparently her former captain janeway
went to bad for her even threatening to
resign but seven opted to abandon her
academy aspirations and become a fenris
ranger this chain of events mirrors
concerns that seven of nine expressed
more than once since star trek voyager
when she considered staying behind in
the delta quadrant because she feared
that she would not be accepted on earth
it seems that her beliefs were
well-founded
one of the many unresolved questions
fans had about star trek voyager is what
became of the doctor's autonomous
holographic emitter a piece of 29th
century technology picked up during the
crew's time travel adventure in future's
end the device allows the doctor to
leave the confines of not just the
sickbay but the ship entirely and it
gives him a freedom of movement that
makes him more like a human than ever
before but how would starfleet feel
about using such an advanced piece of
tech seemingly in violation of the
temporal prime directive here we find
out and it seems that the doctor's
mobile emitter has become a piece of
invaluable technology found aboard the
la serena as she struggles with the
board queen while on board the ship
dratty is able to power up the vessel's
ech however this is not the emergency
command hologram first seen in the star
trek voyager episode tinker tenor dr spy
on an emergency combat hologram turns
out this ship can make a hologram from
anyone who's ever been on board
including an emergency combat hologram
this hologram which is in the image of
the crew's deadly romulan cohort elenor
sports what appears to be an updated
version of the mobile emitter which is
used to keep borg forces and the jaradi
queen at bay though we learn little
about the device holographic eleanor
points out that he exists separate from
the ship's systems to keep the lockout
codes out of the queen's reach elner
also suggests that not only is the 29th
century device lived on but may now be
in regular use throughout starfleet
since beginning of the season picard's
mother yvette has played a major role in
the story yvette is only seen once since
star trek the next generation when she
appears during the hallucination that
the captain experiences while traveling
through an unusual region of space in
the season one episode where no one has
gone before in that distant part of the
galaxy thoughts become reality and
picard finds himself face to face with
his mother in his hallucinatory vision
yvette picard asks her son to sit with
her for a cup of tea in a chat this
can't be
you've been
dead but i'm always with you
you know that
in this episode of picard we learn the
exact nature of that tragic death at
first this seems like an irreconcilable
retcon with yvette dying as a young
woman rather than the elderly version we
saw on star trek the next generation
even as a hallucination how could picard
remember her as an old woman if she
never was one but apparently the writers
thought about this picard says that long
after her death he often imagined her
having grown older and inviting him for
a cup of tea and chats as an old woman
it's a clever easter egg for longtime
fans that helps resolve a potential plot
hole in a satisfying way
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]